hot breath trent babb asks do you write
random jokes and group them later or
stick to one theme until finished and
this could also parlay into like
wayne flake asking what is your favorite
writing technique
so do you use random jokes and group
them together or stick them in a theme
later and what technique do you enjoy
when you're creating this uh material
close so
i think it's you know i just write what
comes to me or things that are
you know on my mind or get stuck in my
craw and
um emotions and feelings and
relationships
um that are affecting me what's
happening to me right now is how i write
and i later find
uh a string or a thread to
weave them all together and the most
difficult part of that is like
obviously if i write a joke about going
to chipotle high it's like where does
that fit in
there's always going to be one that's
like an out layer
where you're like is this going to go in
because i don't have anywhere to really
put it
because i'm someone who really likes to
have it flow and make sense
it's like you know it's a script it's
it's
in some ways it can be very funny to go
from talking about
you know i'm looking around my house
whatever buying a new land and then
being like
so my dad's a dick you know like
obviously you can smash things up
together to make
them funny in that way but i also like
having it be
have me flow from subject to subject and
you go how did we get
from growing up in sex ed class to
the metoo movement i mean whatever like
you just how did we get from here to
there
and and having you even think about it
having just
flowing with me so i i definitely string
them together
consciously callbacks come
probably the latest you know as you're
putting finishing touches on it where
you're like
what would blow callbacks blow an
audience's mind
so if you strategically place them um
that's important and i'm willing to
change and add things up until the last
minute
and the way that i write mostly
is scribbling things down in my notes
on my computer it's all threaded through
um connected to my phone so it's like if
i put
you know i'll do the notes app i'll do
voice memos
but i rarely go back and listen or
record every set but i really go back
and listen to my voice memos of joke
ideas
i need to do that it's on the to-do list
got a couple months
um and writing little notebooks
everywhere so the that can be bad
because
i'll go back through a notebook after i
it it i'm
i'm also like instinctually
editing you can say like oh i'll look
back and think like
i should have worked harder on this or
that and it's like
going on the road and over periods of of
months and times like
i just do it so i think i'm not working
because i didn't sit down and work with
it but if i listen to a set from 2017
and then 2019 i did it just because it
was trial and error so i didn't sit down
and
but i did it and so it doesn't that's
why my that that constant feeling of i
should be working i should be working
it's like
by thinking about it by doing it you're
working
because i just i tell i test jokes
by not open mics fight by headlining
sets i mean like that's just sort of
like
or local shows around l.a i mean again
this is all
obsolete now because we're in a pandemic
but
yeah sometimes the first time you try it
it's very close to what it will be
and other times you're saying something
wrong potentially problematic until you
figure out
the missing piece that will get you to
the punch line
you